we're told cassand was curious if
triangle abc and triangle gfe were
congruent so he tried to map one figure
onto the other using a rotation so let's
see this is triangle a b c and it looks
like at first
he rotates triangle abc about point c to
get it right over here so that's what
they're depicting in this diagram
and then they say kasan kassan concluded
it is not possible to map triangle abc
onto triangle gfe using a sequence of
rigid transformations so the triangles
are not congruent
so what i want you to do is pause this
video and think about is cassand correct
that they are not congruent because you
cannot map abc triangle abc onto
triangle gfe with rigid transformations
all right
so the way i think about it he was able
to do the rotation that got us right
over here
so there's rotation about point c and so
this point right over here let me make
sure i get this right this would have
become b prime and then this is a prime
and then c is mapped to itself so c is
equal to c prime but he's not done
there's another rigid transformation he
could do and that would be a reflection
about the line fg
so if he reflects about the line fg then
this point is going to be mapped to
point e just like that and then if you
did that you would see that there is a
series of rigid transformations that
maps triangle abc onto triangle gfe
so kasan is not correct he missed one
more transformation he could have done
which is a reflection